let's go next to our caller from the
five seven zero area code who's calling
today from five seven zero
hey David that me yes it is hey what's
going on this is Nick uh yes I what's
your video yesterday or a couple days
ago about Bernie Sanders new proposal in
terms of campaign finance reform right
now obviously I'm super for this I'm
pretty sure a large majority I think
they pulled it one time about ninety
percent of Americans are for source or
some sort of campaign finance reform and
just overall finance reform in general
for politics so it always interested me
that this these things never get past I
think burns proposals the pension super
effective if it's implemented even some
parts of it I wanted to ask you what do
you think some of the issues at hand it
being not being able to pass with such a
you know large majority in public
opinion especially you know you talk
about things like gun control having
such a large majority about things like
using universal background checks
wanting to be passed but at the end of
the day I think this might even be more
important and lead to other changes so
what do you think are some of the big
obstacles standing in the way of it well
the biggest obstacle is that it's hard
to get people who are in power because
of the system we have to change the
system that that's like fundamentally
the obstacle so as you're pointing out I
don't know the poll you're talking about
but it wouldn't surprise me that ninety
percent of the country wants at least
some kind of campaign finance reform
those aren't the people who are in
positions of power because of the system
right someone who works in the local
bricklayers Union or whatever that wants
campaign finance reform they didn't get
their job the way that a senator did
because of the system of campaign
finance that we have and so the senator
is not going to want to change that
system so number one is we need to start
electing at every level of government
people who are committed to doing
campaign finance reform but there's also
logistical obstacles so like for example
one of the tenets one of the ideas of
Bernie's campaign finance reform money
out of politics plan is you start doing
public financing
of Elections you're not going to be able
to even make any headway on that for as
long as the prevailing law of the land
is that money is speech right so then
you now have to link that provision to
can we overturn or somehow undo citizens
united and so the the real obstacle is
that a lot of you know Bernie laid out
enough different proposals that some
could be handled legislatively some
could maybe be done by executive order
but there is stuff in there that you
know isn't for as long as money is
speech it's going to be very difficult
to do a lot of those things and so there
are the obstacles are systemic and they
are big but they are worth tackling for
sure as it sounds like you agree with
yeah that's true I totally agree at that
point of course the Citizens United case
I feel like agree with you on yet that
has to be overturned for any headway to
be made on there additionally on top of
that do you think you know ferny is
elected a lot of those initiatives will
get pushed initially through executive
order do you think they'll be maybe some
bipartisan support in the House and
Senate to you know I don't know the
answer I would I would really have to
look at the list because not everything
is even potentially doable by executive
order so I would need to really look at
the list first to even see what is
conceivably doable by executive order I
don't have the answer for you right now
all right great yeah thanks for taking
my call then all right I appreciate it
thank you so much hope to hear from you
again that was Nick great to hear from
Nick